okay today we're going to look at a
super interesting interview with a
republican senator
actually being forced to go beyond the
talking points when questioned by fox
news host chris wallace it's really easy
to simply say you know we can't increase
the deficit
we don't have the money for things
democrats want to do where is the money
going to come from now of course we know
that they never ask those questions when
it's about defense spending or war or
tax cuts for the rich we know about that
double standard but it doesn't matter
because if they're not questioned about
those talking points there are lots of
people who buy it hey yeah billions
hundreds of billions that sounds crazy
how do we afford this stuff and if
they're not questioned about it they
never really have to explain what they
mean and you get a lot of republican
voters who end up agreeing with you now
similarly
when republicans say
biden's infrastructure plan is too
expensive it's not all really
infrastructure it's filled with crap
when they say biden's job plan is just
spending money we don't have
it's easy as long as you never have to
explain anything but when you do have to
explain well okay
which of these things would you cut
which of these are not worthy
elements for this plan
something interesting happens first of
all they almost never have actual
answers and secondly it throws them off
so badly that they often end up exposing
other garbage talking points that they
also typically are allowed to get away
with so let's dive right in this is fox
host chris wallace asking republican
senator bill cassidy all right uh
senator sir
which specific parts of the biden jobs
plan would you cut there's workforce
development there's there's child care
you know all these different
elements of it cassidy has no answers
and instead just start slamming teachers
unions and it starts to get pretty
unhinged take a look up on the screen
a hundred billion dollars for workforce
development 400 billion dollars to care
for the elderly and disabled 225 billion
dollars for child care and 200 billion
dollars for free preschool senator
which of those programs that i just put
up which of those programs do you think
people in your state don't need
every one of those programs should be
evaluated if it's important it should be
advanced it's not infrastructure when
people say wait a second i like this
because we need a new bridge across the
kaukasu river in lake charles i'm saying
this plan will not give it to you the
amount of spending for roads and bridges
is so low
that and split between 50 states over
five years you're not going to get your
bridge now we may need this by the way
we just are restarting our uh
our our bipartisan working group to come
at family support for the dependent
children and elderly but that is not
going to give you a road and bridge and
that's what people in my state would
really like to see okay so so far
he doesn't say any of the programs are
bad
but he says they're not infrastructure
but again this is a jobs plan they're
all job related
uh and they are you know education
developing a workforce these are even i
would argue parts of infrastructure in
the 21st century
but then cassidy says
well this won't get my constituents all
the things they want this money is going
to go to all 50 states
that's not really a reason to oppose the
bill unless your expectation
is that all the money goes to your state
but that's not how federal spending
works and it's not infrastructure but
again it's a jobs bill so so far
this is the lightest questioning in
other countries you would be
ridiculed as a journalist if you didn't
ask these questions and in the united
states with these unprepared buffoons
just asking the obvious questions gets
you to a point of realizing this this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
let's continue
yeah but but i guess the question is and
you know we could argue and i have uh
back and forth with both sides about
infrastructure but there are a lot of
programs that aren't infrastructure and
the question i'm asking you
is should
would you support the government paying
for them i mean
i i looked into it in your state of
louisiana the
the rate of child poverty is 25 one in
four of the children in louisiana are in
poverty and according to the white house
42 percent
of residents
in louisiana do not have access to
child care so
don't they want wouldn't they benefit
forget whether it's infrastructure or
not wouldn't they benefit from these
government programs
so i don't know if they would
if you think about the main driver of
elevating out of poverty it's good
education now what we saw in the
pandemic was teachers unions keeping
schools shut
even when the centers for disease
control said it was safe to go back the
president wants to give universal pre-k
run by the same teachers unions now if
you're in chicago
and there's more money going to the
school systems into the unions and yet
they still won't open so he's asked
specifically child poverty is a real
problem in louisiana child poverty is a
problem in the united states it's an
even bigger problem in louisiana
and this bill helps child poverty
isn't that something to be glad that the
bill addresses well i don't know says
cassidy teachers unions forced schools
to close during the pandemic
zero substantive engagement with the
topics at hand and then it continues to
just be an alternate reality wallace
shows cassidy you know the trump tax
cuts you supported
speaking of spending those tax cuts
disproportionately helped the rich and
they increased the deficit which he
claims to be concerned about now when
it's joe biden and cassidy ignores the
substance and says oh you know
unemployment rates were really low
before the pandemic i want to take a
look at those tax cuts according to the
tax policy center
the average first year tax cut for a
household making less than 25 thousand
dollars the average tax cut was just
sixty dollars the average tax cut for a
household making 3.4 million dollars was
193
000
and contrary to talk that it will pay
for itself the trump tax cuts are now
projected to add one and a half trillion
dollars to the deficit over 10 years
senator of the 2 million tax filers in
louisiana only 14 000 of them were
paying more and filing gross income of
more than five hundred thousand dollars
so what's wrong
uh with raising the top tax rate
to where it was during the bush 43 and
obama administrations in order to help
the working and middle class
if all you do is look at first degree
effects
chris you can make a point like that it
sounds just like president biden
speaking to speak in the congress and
i'm not accusing you i'm just pointing
that out if you look at the overall
effect the aspiration of this biden
administration is to return to the
economy we had before covid where we had
record low unemployment which means
record high employment for african
americans veterans women hispanics the
disabled so after throwing in that shot
about hey chris you sound like joe biden
because you're asking real questions
cassidy tries to argue that that deficit
increase thanks to trump's tax cuts is
only a first order effect and then you
know the second order effects would be
that the economy grows so much that the
tax cut pays for itself it simply didn't
happen the deficit increased
and then it increased more and okay then
covet hit but we know that the tax cuts
for the rich are not revenue positive
even in the long term it's been studied
for decades and then cassidy says as
evidence
look at job creation before the pandemic
but after trump's tax cuts remember once
again
job creation under uh trump was just a
slightly slowed down continuation of
what we saw under barack obama slowed
down
his 2017 tax bill
didn't go into effect until 2018
which was reflected in people's taxes
filed in 2019 that's the timeline does
not add up
let's look at just the last bit here and
there does seem to be like a child
crying in the background during this
piece that that's not that's part of the
clip high school dropouts with wage
growth disproportionately in the lower
and lower quintiles of the income
structure that's where we were seeing
the economy really help now that was all
part of the tax cut and jobs act bill
you can't separate them and so if you
want to say my gosh these people are
making more money uh why don't we return
and keep the tax cut in jobs act that's
that's the flip side of the question
you're asking and i think that flip side
is the part that should be emphasized
but the argument is and there certainly
is some data to indicate that the trump
tax cuts benefited the wealthy and
corporations more than they did the
working and middle class chris wallace
is trying
but this is simply going nowhere they do
not have answers
for any of this they simply move on to
something else which programs would you
cut
doesn't say but bashes teachers unions
teachers unions are bad well what about
the deficit oh yeah but job creation in
2017 was was really great it's pathetic
and they should be subjected to this
type of questioning in every interview
my senses if this became
the standard on fox news
a lot of these officials would stop
doing fox news interviews and indeed
my understanding is that there are
increasingly republicans who are turning
down interviews with chris wallace
because he's just asking basic questions
that any reporter in just about every
country
would be expected to ask they fall apart
the talking points never made sense but
if there's no pushback in fact sometimes
it's not that there isn't pushback from
the hosts it's they cheerlead they oh
right of course yeah right right yeah
but democrats don't don't understand
that but yes of course you're right
senator
as soon as there's basic pushback they
fall apart we'll have more examples like
this
on our instagram page which you can
follow at david pakman show
the great daniel goldman will be joining
me after this short break really looking
forward to this interview